all right good evening everybody
we are halfway there and by the end of
tonight if all goes well
assuming time doesn't stop moving uh
assuming mike pence doesn't
throw off the progress of time as we
understand it we will be three quarters
of the way done with this
depraved and delusional despicable
diabolical uh republican national
convention
after tonight so it is it is going to be
a long night i'm going to go through the
schedule momentarily we are mike pence
is sort of like the headliner
and i don't know if he's going to have
to be chaperoned as many of you know
mike pence
there's something weird going on about
when he's allowed to be around women and
you know all this different weird stuff
i don't know um but we're gonna find out
about all of it very very soon in fact
let's do that now um headlining today is
mike pence who will formally accept his
renomination
his wife karen pence will speak she's
just
horrible we're going to hear from marsha
blackburn who's
terrible uh dede byrne i i don't know
who that is madison cawthorne
uh i am vaguely familiar with kellyanne
conway who of course
is quitting at the end of the month
we're gonna hear from dan crenshaw who
is uh
horrible is going to be speaking
scott dane i don't know uh lager and
trucker of minnesota okay
senator joni ernst is an absolute
lunatic we're gonna hear from her
richard grinnell
clarence henderson keith kellogg michael
mchale
christie gnome i'm familiar with
bergesse
owens elise stefanik is a bomb throwing
congresswoman lara trump continuing
the nepotism and then lee zeldin a
republican congressman from new york so
that's on schedule for today along with
probably a bunch of
uh propaganda we also are going to be
monitoring
very closely we're going to be watching
trump's twitter like the zapruder
film to see what we see there and then i
will also be live tweeting throughout
uh you can follow me on twitter at
dpakman and by the way i'm going to be
talking about this tomorrow
very very precisely um as you can see
the national polling has tightened in
the last two months where now
biden and trump are seven points apart
earlier i posted
that if you look back at august 27th of
2016 which
is exactly so i'm i'm using this on the
show tomorrow which is why i did august
27th
uh by i'm sorry clinton and trump were
only as you can see
6.3 points apart four years ago today
the difference in august 27 numbers
from 2016 to now is 0.7 points and there
have been people who take to emailing me
whenever i say hey guys biden can win
hey guys
assume nothing everybody's got people
say david
you're just gaslighting pretending it's
closer than it is
to get people to vote it's like first of
all telling people that until the votes
are counted the polls mean nothing is
not gaslighting that's number one so
please
put that argument in the trash but
number two
the difference between right now and
where we were four years ago
is 0.7 points nationally now you can say
well the swing states are more in
biden's favor
whatever we didn't have the post office
involved in a political way in 2016.
we didn't have you know you guys
understand so i i'm assuming i don't
have to explain it to you guys
um so we're going to deal with that and
and talk about that
uh tomorrow so don't miss tomorrow's
podcast and
you know all of that different stuff we
are continuing to have the number of
twitch subscribers up on the screen
people seem to like yesterday and some
people wrote
to me that they liked
being able to sign up and see the number
tick up automatically so we're going to
keep that
up on the screen it's working
beautifully we also
again are going with a goal of 56
website members and patrons today why
because that's what we got on monday
we fell short of that yesterday let's
just see if we can do 56 why not
there's really no particular science to
the numbers
okay i do want to look at a few super
chats that are coming in
um maybe we'll start there
and yesterday the super chats were
pouring in very very powerfully
chaka seki says i am deeply afraid
of what lovecraftian horrors await us
tonight well said will trump finally
reveal that he is the blind idiot god
as a thoth that i doubt
uh jackie tupper has subscribed our
friend azeem abu khalil says has trump
successfully sabotaged the election by
removing copious sorting machines from
swing states
how do we counter this flagrant
corruption you guys know how we counter
it
everybody must vote no matter what
everybody must vote if we need to crawl
over broken glass we do it
few other youtube subscribers coming in
unknown prodigy says you forgot
dumb disgraceful dreadful and douchey
yes tonight will be a
despicable depraved and diabolical
dumb disgraceful dreadful and douchey
republican national convention jr says
who have we i'm going to have to mute
every time i go live people start going
absolutely crazy texting me about what's
gonna happen tonight so i apologize for
that
jr says who have we become as people
as a country when does enough actually
become enough
how dark does insanity have to look
before enough people come to their
senses and refuse to remain stupid
where is reason hiding it's not hiding
at the rnc
that i can tell you with certainty matt
bond says as
elvis said help me make it through the
night yeah it's
some people in the chat are noticing
that i'm basically
sick of this bs convention you're you're
right i mean it's despicable it really
is
ryan mcknight says thank you for your
hard work
i am a former republican turned slightly
left of center
you are my favorite progressive voice
because you seem to be the most
objective
and introspective keep up the good work
thank you ryan i appreciate that
uh have you marched in any blm protests
no i talked about this i mean at the
time when they were going on in boston
the pandemic was fully raging
as many of you know i agree with many of
the broader goals of blm but
uh not with some of the particulars of
the organization so i'm doing my
activism through the show
i'm influencing far more people than
adding one more protester
to blm protests would add and the i was
not particularly interested in
being around large crowds during the uh
height of the pandemic
let's see timon mansil says i hate all
this violence that's going on in
wisconsin makes me sad that we cannot
work it out with words
i i agree zest the african asks whether
i miss ralph nader i interviewed him not
long ago i don't
particularly miss him the 90s rapper
says i know you did you don't get to
pick the ads that run on your channel
but i can only watch the same
epoch times ad so many times before i
want to barf
i apologize for that although i have
nothing to do with it
and mark raybould says i forget is the
rnc theme tonight the 180
000 covet deaths theme or militia
murdering people in the streets theme
it's neither
it's donald trump has been the best for
black people
other than maybe abe lincoln that's the
theme we are anticipating tonight
let me say thank you to some people on
twitch who have uh signed up
scar door has raided with a party of 141
people
welcome everybody and come on in jp
the beast already exists is supporting
and bajango 15 has subscribed with prime
and says
pacman i love you also thanks to ben's
tater tots
for subscribing with prime you are
subscriber
[Music]
1360
some people asking whether the 15th
anniversary coupon code
still works on my website it does but
i'm not making a big deal out of it but
it does
we celebrated the 15th anniversary of
the david pakman show on sunday
it turns out i was wrong by six days the
real anniversary was
august 16th i just got the date wrong
it's
i mean it's crazy but i got the date
wrong but on august 23rd we celebrated
it and there is a coupon code
15 year that's one five year
it'll work at joinpakman.com i'm not
promoting it it was supposed to be a one
day thing
but it still works you could use it
at joinpakman.com if you understand
and i will of course thank you
and this blue bar that is sadly empty at
zero right now
will start to fill up if we're lucky
looks like the rnc
is not going to start at all early today
the last couple of nights they've had
some
video presentations that started a
little early but we are getting very
close
at the bottom of the hour um
let's see here super chats continue to
pour in
violently let's see here
master 101 says should dems moderate
their position on abortion
no the country is more in favor of
abortion today
than ever since uh roe v wade so it
would not make sense for democrats to do
that the position is
more than more than moderate enough
brian holliday says nba players
boycotting playing in the playoff game
after police shooting of jacob blake
what are your thoughts i think it's
powerful i mean it's
you know there's people on the right who
are saying oh nobody was watching the
nba anyway
all right well then just you weren't
watching and you're still not watching
but i do think it's actually a pretty
powerful message
patrick asher says opinions on the
shooting in wisconsin
we talked about it on the bonus should
it bonus show today
and i'm gonna have a bigger piece about
it tomorrow
um so obviously i'm sure my my thoughts
are
what is obvious to many um but
i will be talking about it in detail
tomorrow we continue to have this sort
of weird
um jagged video i don't know how else to
describe it
from the official rnc feed so we're
going to kick over to a different feed
we will keep a closed captioning on
and we're mostly going to carry the big
speeches and then i want to be hearing
from you guys via super chat and
elsewhere
um but some of this propaganda material
we didn't cover yesterday people
nobody seemed to miss it let me put it
that way
thanks to twilight sentinel jewels
uh and jewels for subscribing with
twitch prime
uh the dude says david may seem
objective but from the standpoint of
sleeper agents let us not forget he is
technically asian
and therefore a chinese plant no i i am
asian
i'm asian hispanic but i'm not chinese i
never
it's listen guys the entire asian thing
was not
a joke it was um related to
ashkenazi jews being a levantine
population that's it
a couple people wrote to me they thought
i was telling some kind of crass joke
when i
it's not a joke just google it it's
actually super interesting
um andrew moore says i'm so proud of the
mba we can't accept the normalization of
these atrocities anymore
agreed very much agreed jacob ratner
asks what do you think of the situation
in wisconsin i will deal with that
tomorrow
by the way it's my birthday happy
birthday jacob very much appreciate your
support over the last
uh period of time hope you have a great
birthday
carol and richie have signed up michael
says love your show
thank you charlie says yo d pacman
months ago i heard some
david pakman show song how can i hear
this amazing track again
i might be able to play it for you
actually let me see if we have it
uh if i have it in an easy place
um i actually don't know where it is
uh i i just don't know exactly where it
is
i would play it for you if i had it
songs
no i'm looking on our dropbox
you'd think it'd be under would it be
under memes and funny pictures it's not
though
yeah i don't know okay uh rabbi
arik sparrow is speaking today we are
not
taking the religious components as many
of you know
i'm culturally and ethnically jewish i
have no problem with rabbis in principle
but i just believe that politics and
religion should be separate in the
united states
so we're not taking the religious
elements but you don't need
to email me and tell me that i'm being
hostile to christianity or anything
this guy's certainly not a christian and
we can all relax about that we're just
not not going to do that right now
connor brenner says i don't know if i'll
be able to get through crenshaw he makes
me want to scream at my screen like a
buffoon good luck lol that's going to be
tonight's going to be tough
i'm not going to lie guys it's going to
be tough lotsa jello says would love if
you had a long-form discussion with
steven
destiny bonnell ii sometime soon all
right
he's in europe right now so i can't
imagine he's streaming this late right
maybe he is
nicholas silva says what do you think of
the defense from the right
what do you think the defense from the
right will be about the right-wing
militia conspiring with the police
i don't know yet i i want to put my
thoughts together about that before i
say
too too much more about it a few people
i do want to thank though
jack paris is new member number one
tonight at joinpacman.com kicking us off
uh carissa staley is new member number
two
mullins is number three jared placek
is number four and thomas de la cerda
is number five kicking us off
at joinpackman.com always much
appreciated
um thanks to tw oh i thank twilight
already
chaka seki says via super chat should we
expect a good people on both sides dog
whistle
from the mangy laut in chief supporting
kyle rittenhouse
and his shooting of protesters i
wouldn't be i'm not expecting it but i
certainly wouldn't be shocked
yeah that's the way i would put it donna
williams
asks what are my thoughts about trump
using the white house as a prop
immoral and possibly illegal those are
my thoughts
super guy says david's bonus show is lit
yeah one of the membership benefits if
you sign up on my website is we do like
an extra show every day
just for members and over the weekend i
had um firefighters visit my house at 4
00 am
and i tell the story on the monday bonus
show twilight sentinel
if i didn't thank you i am thanking you
again
okay uh apologies for that i think i've
now thanked you twice maybe even three
times but you know what you tricked me
you tricked me emily maiden says
watching this horror show from europe in
the middle of the night keep up the
great coverage can't watch and stay
sane without you thanks emily i
appreciate that
cooper mccartney says i'm from canada
the electoral college confuses me what's
your opinion
i'm not confused by it i'm very much
familiar with it
but certainly it's confusing in terms of
whether it's a logical system
but i'm certainly not confused about how
it works
paul clark says do you still speak to
louis yes it's l-o-u-i-s much love to
him yes i speak to lewis regularly
saw him about 10 days ago um
we are at the uh requisite point in the
evening where people ask if i ever look
at twitch chat
i do let's get to our first speaker i'm
governor christie gnome
of south dakota let's get some volume
i'm here tonight
because i believe america is an
exceptional nation
founded on three principles equality
freedom
and opportunity but today our founding
principles
are under attack this year the choice
for americans is between a man who
values these ideals
and all that can be built because of
them and a man who isn't guided by these
ideals
and coincidentally has built nothing
america's battle for independence and
fight for self-governance was something
that had never been done before
men of great intellect and wisdom like
james madison
the father of our constitution hoped our
constitutional republic would last for
ages
mitigate the problems that would
naturally arise from political factions
and prevent tyranny madison also
authored much of the bill of rights
because he understood the natural
tendency of government to increasingly
encroach on the people's consent
and thus our freedom he urged his
colleagues to adopt these amendments to
enshrine in our constitution the ideals
laid out in the declaration of
independence
that all power comes from the people
that the government has created and
ought to be exercised for the benefit of
the people
our constitution guarantees the right to
speak
to assemble and to worship the right to
arm ourselves
as a counterbalance to a standing army
and the right to a fair and equitable
criminal justice system
we must fight to protect these
foundational rights from government
interference
and indifference america is unique
in the world government's power at all
levels
is limited to the confines of our
constitution which protects our
god-given liberties
and civil rights we are not
and will not be the subjects of an elite
class of so-called
experts we the people this speech is
interesting because it's a generic
small government conservatism type
speech it just has nothing to do with
trump or what with why
anybody would vote for him to be
president for four more years than
anybody
when he was just 28 years old honest abe
saw wild and furious passions worse than
savage mops he said
taking the place of reason judgment he
was alarmed
by the increasing disregard for the rule
of law throughout the country
he was concerned for the people that had
seen their property destroyed
their families attacked and their lives
threatened or even taken away
these good people were becoming tired of
and disgusted with a government that
offered them no protection
sound familiar it took 244
years to build this great nation flaws
and all
but we stand to lose it in a tiny
fraction of that time if we continue
down the path taken by the democrats
and their radical supporters remember by
every empirical measure the country does
better under democratic presidents we
can evaluate why
or whether we should care but that's the
facts
the violence is rampant there's looting
chaos destruction and murder yeah and
trump is president so how would another
four years stop that
the people that can't good hard-working
americans
are left to fend for themselves
the republican party's commitment to
individual rights and self-government is
as necessary today
as it was in 1860 when we won our first
presidential election
our party respects individuals based on
who they are
we don't divide people based on their
beliefs or their roots
we don't shun people who think for
themselves
we respect everyone equally under the
constitution
and we treat them as martin luther king
jr wished
according to the content of their
character not the color of their skin
in just four years president trump has
lifted people of all races and
backgrounds out of poverty
he shrunk government he put money back
into the pockets
of hard-working ordinary americans he
has advanced religious
liberty he protected the second
amendment
you can look back 50 years you won't
find anyone
that has surpassed president trump's
success on these four issues alone
history chooses its heroes
for the time in which they live at our
founding
madison was one of the chosen when the
nation's do you think trump is like
madison
was lincoln's turn lincoln thanks to
these men america
is a land of hope their examples have
been repeated in countless ways by
simple americans following their
conscience
but there is another american hero to be
recognized
not trump that is the common american
this is who president trump is fighting
for
he's fighting for you
an abrupt end to a delusional speech
having no connection to donald trump
notice it was mostly about abe lincoln
and then at the end she's like
and trump is the modern good guy that's
fighting for everybody
um okay uh
i think we're gonna not carry this one
this is the logging executive i don't
know if people
necessarily wanna hear from a logging
executive right now
um but i do wanna get to a few of the
other
super chats that are coming in um i'm
gonna do the best i can to get to
to most of them jamie says an ad popped
up on my phone inviting me to become
canadian i'm tempted david thank you for
covering this so i don't have to watch
alone
semi truck driver asks if i've ever
voted for a republican i don't think so
i don't think so nicole says backing off
semi truck driver and why
backing off semi truck driver and why oh
my god i don't know what's going on
there
aaron dadas asks if the christie gnomes
speech would win over a single vote
probably it'll probably win a vote and
lose a vote i don't know
connor brenner says remember this is the
governor that thought her anti-meth
campaign
entitled meth we're on it was a good
idea is that could that possibly be true
she also entertained conversation with
trump about him ending up on mount
rushmore
i thought that that was debunked
mazzy z says tell that to your native
residents christie you don't treat them
equally
michael anton sue says like your show
and tyt tom hartman stephanie miller
show and many others that are
progressive all great people
tom was on with me last week i
interviewed him bay photo says wonder if
she brought
biker rhona virus with her i read that
the people who were going to be
at mike pence's speech today will not be
tested for coronavirus that's what i
that's what was announced
today thanks to concubar
for subscribing with twitch prime and
invisiblesith
who is subscriber 1366
over on twitch which i appreciate
adrumph twitter says david talk me off
the ledge
and out of rehab i think trump ekes out
a win
effective enough gaslighting and voter
suppression
i can't tell you you're wrong and that's
why we all have to vote
c asks my opinion of dc statehood i
favor it i favor it now let's go to bomb
thrower marsha blackburn
i'm u.s senator marsha blackburn from
tennessee
america is a nation of heroes in times
of difficulty we're reminded that
they're all around
us they're in the line with us at the
grocery store
in the pew with us at church they're the
regular
americans who step up to volunteer and
serve
when we need them most they've stood at
the forefront
throughout this pandemic the emergency
room nurses who go back
shift after shift the medical
researchers
developing a vaccine and therapies to
combat
let me give you guys a little heuristic
to apply when you see a speech like this
with stuff nobody could disagree with
we should respect and laud the health
care workers
remember it's an rnc ask yourself the
question
does this imply i should vote for trump
because then you realize
nothing that she's saying has anything
to do with voting for donald trump
another kind of hero the kind democrats
don't recognize because they don't
fit into their narrative i'm talking
about the heroes of our law enforcement
and armed services
leftists try to turn them into villains
they want to cancel them
but i'm here to tell you these heroes
can't be camera framing tennessee is
full of them
after all we're the volunteer state
my dad served in the army in world war
ii
when he came home he put on another
uniform
and for 30 years volunteered to help our
underfunded sheriff's department i'm
reminded of him
whenever i see compassion and
selflessness
in others when i see law enforcement
officers
put their lives on the line every single
day
to keep our communities safe in spite
of the hatred thrown at them
when i see the heroes who volunteer to
serve our country
putting their lives on the line for our
freedom
many of these heroes called tennessee
home and we could not be more proud
of the brave men and women of the 101st
airborne division at fort campbell
the common thread between them is a
deep-seated desire to serve a cause
larger than themselves
they don't believe their country owes
them anything
they believe they they
owe their country and their fellow man
as hard as democrats try they can't
cancel our heroes
they can't contest their bravery
and they can't dismiss the powerful
sense of service that lives
deep in their souls
so they tried to defund them our
military our police
even ice to take away their tools to
keep us
safe joe biden kamala harris
and their radical allies try to destroy
these heroes because
if they're what exactly is radical about
the biden harris policy by the way
radical can control us they close our
churches
but keep the liquor stores and abortion
clinics
open they say we can't gather in
community groups
but encourage protests riots and
looting in the streets if the democrats
had their way
they would keep you locked in your house
until you become dependent on the
government for everything
that sounds a lot like communist china
to me
maybe that's why joe biden is so soft on
them
why nancy pelosi says that china would
prefer
joe biden yep i bet they would
but okay president trump has stood up
for our heroes every day he
stood by our law enforcement our
military
and the freedoms we hold dear
he's made good on his promise to put
america first
and i hope you will stand with me
as we send him back for four
more years with a clear message to the
democrats
it is really interesting how today's
speeches talk about reelecting trump
sort of as an afterthought at the very
end of the speech with no
real case for the re-election oh this
one's over okay here's dan crenshaw
eight years ago in the fields of hellman
province afghanistan
close friend and teammate laid down
cover fire against taliban insurgents so
that i could walk
blind and bloodied to the medevac
helicopter
and survive but he didn't
dave orson was killed two months later
he died a hero to this great country
here's the truth about america we are a
country of
heroes i believe that so should you
we are a people with a common set of
ideals conceived in liberty
people that has sacrificed time and
again for our freedom and the freedom of
others
that's something no other country ever
anywhere can claim
since 9 11 i've seen america's heroes up
close
some of them saved my life some of them
saved many others lives
many of them never made it home these
heroes acted as if the whole struggle
depended on them alone
as if any weakness on their part would
be a reflection of the whole nation
that's called duty and america has a
long history of it
our enemies fear us because americans
fight for good and we know it
it gives us strength when our heroes are
trusted and equipped then freedom
prevails
the defeat of isis was the result of
america believing in our heroes
i didn't think we had defeated them yet
rebuilding our military so we'd have
what we needed to finish the mission
the cowering of the iranian regime and
the restoration of the deterrence once
lost
is the result of america believing in
her own might again
america's heroism isn't relegated to the
battlefield
every single day we see them if you just
know where to look
it's the nurse who volunteers for back
to back shifts caring for covid patients
because she feels that's her duty it's
the parent
we'll relearn algebra because there's no
way they're letting their kid fall
behind while schools are closed
and it's the cop they get spit on one
day and will save a child's life
the next america is the country
where the young military wife with two
young children answers the unexpected
knock at the door
looks the man in uniform in the eye and
even as her whole world comes crashing
down
she stands up straight she holds back
tears and takes care of her family
because she must this is what heroism
looks like
it's who we are nation of heroes
we need you now more than ever we need
to remind ourselves what heroism really
is
heroism is self-sacrifice it's not
moralizing and lecturing over others
when they disagree
heroism is grace not perpetual outrage
heroism is rebuilding our communities
not destroying them
heroism is renewing faith in the symbols
that unite us not
tearing them down see america is a
fabric
it's woven from the threads of history's
best stories best attributes and
greatest ideas
the american spirit reflects the oldest
and most important virtues
self-sacrifice courage tolerance love of
country
grace and passion for human achievement
we can decide right now that american
greatness will not be rejected nor
squandered
as the american founding was grounded in
individual liberty
so we'll be our future but if we are to
rediscover our strength
then it must be an endeavor undertaken
by each and every one of us
we must become the heroes that we so
admire
america was built by them and our future
will be protected by them
it will be protected by you so god bless
america
[Music]
all right so we will um step away just
briefly here as we heard from marsha
blackburn and from dan crenshaw two of
the top
uh and i use that term loosely scheduled
speeches today
i do want to say thanks to cabin for
gifting 10 subscriptions
over on twitch um let's see
a couple of interesting questions i
wanted to get to here ryan waltman
asks do i think this rnc is turning off
more moderate republicans than enticing
more trumpists
i think it's very difficult to make that
assessment i just think we're not going
to know and it's really going to be a
turnout election in the end and not
about actually
swaying that many votes um
oh we're in the middle of a level four
hype train that's beautiful that's
extraordinary what's going on
tj asks would tool see gabbard be an
easier sell to voters
to republican or democratic voters i
think either way the answer is no
chakuseki says someone should tell
delusional twit blackburn about cancel
culture
espoused against goodyear by blotus
who has more spare tires than the
michelin man
chakaseki i need you writing material
for me i really do
sharpie diesel says does anyone feel
like they've just tuned in to the 700
club
very much so very much so
uh what else is on folks minds here
most wise one says american liberty was
built on free expression not your
autocratic lies
uh they don't seem to know or care i
don't know which which of the two
epoxy says crenshaw sounds like he's
rehearsing a 2024 pitch
alex lichtenstein says who was who is
better teeth
anthony fantano or ben shapiro actually
i'm glad you mentioned fantano
i keep trying to remember to put a note
in my phone
about i need to ask fantano for a favor
and i'm gonna put a note i just put a
note in my to do's for tomorrow
it's a doozy of a to-do list tomorrow
and i gotta reach out to fantano i think
fantano has the better teeth for sure
no no question about it whatsoever okay
i don't want to
fall behind on thanking people so while
this gentleman is speaking i do want to
say
thanks to sean spencer who's new member
number six on my website today
carol timko is new member number seven
joseph avery and lauren pitt mcclelland
are numbers
eight and nine getting us into double
digits is silvia martinez at number 10.
lauren stern is number 11. angelina
wright
12. taylor grendel lucky 13. cara
clement is
14 we're on fire elizabeth gordon hughes
is new member number 15.
justin harding is 16 aj adams
17 trey beatty 18
and sean wagner number 19. oh sorry
and brendan sutherland that's weird
number 20
explosive situation on my website
unbelievable unbelievable um
okay i'm gonna stay away from anything
listen guys
like i said yesterday you know making
fun of melania's accent
it's beneath us and anything related to
dan
crenshaw's injury i i just don't find it
super f i think it's beneath us so i'm
going to stay away from that type of
thing
becky hussman says can you do member
only youtube chat for 30 minutes
it's not a bad idea it's not a bad idea
let's do this
um yeah let's look at doing that a
little bit later in the evening i don't
think that that's a bad idea i
i i would certainly consider that and i
think that that's an interesting idea
knowhow says pro gaming team de ogres
love you david yeehaw oh i appreciate
that
i don't know much about it but i like it
kevin escobar says
walks off even in major league soccer
atlanta united walked off tonight in
solidarity with the protests in the nba
not rnc but i'm sure trump will say
something about it
not not surprising um and i would not be
shocked
if we did hear something from donald
trump on that issue
i do want to say thanks to x-ray vision
for subscribing over on twitch if you're
just joining us
we do have mike pence scheduled as sort
of the headliner tonight we will also
hear
from karen pence we've already heard
from senator marcia blackburn we heard
from congressman dan crenshaw
we heard from south dakota governor
christie gnome
let me see who else was scheduled today
we heard from a logging executive
uh oh okay so the other folks that i'm
very much aware of
congresswoman elise stefanik we will be
hearing from
eric trump's wife lara trump congressman
lee zeldin
those are really the people i m oh and
joni earns oh and kellyanne conway so we
actually we have a lot still to go
um and still a full two hours
uh to go in the evening's presentation
i'm curious as to whether there will be
more of these little montages of events
done where trump is put out there with
like normal people
and he just can't relate to anybody and
it's like
super super awkward let's listen to a
little bit of this one
the wife and mother to share how
education freedom has personally
impacted
my family especially education freedom
is code for defund public schools
remember that kids
was even born i was told his life
wouldn't be worth living
toad early tests revealed he had down
syndrome
our doctor encouraged me to terminate
the pregnancy
he said if you do not you will be
burdening your life
your family and your community
i knew my baby was a human being
created by god and that made him worthy
of
life i am thankful that president trump
values the life of the unborn
when we went to register samuel for
kindergarten
we were told to just put him where he
was okay so i'm going to interrupt
these unconscionable rantings about how
we should be defunding
a public school and banning abortion
what i do want to remind you guys
is only if you believe
that let me let me just go back
does anyone believe donald trump was
pro-choice until age 68 and then
suddenly became pro-life just before he
ran for president like is that
believable to anybody in my audience if
so
i have a bridge to sell you right um
and this is just a line that is repeated
ad nauseum about how trump is a man
against abortion and all of this stuff i
don't even believe it
and uh in any case i questioned the
value of pushing the abortion issue at
this point given that the country is
more in favor of abortion today
than it has been at any time since roe v
wade
um but i wouldn't be shocked if trump
paid for people's abortions
uh and and maybe pressured people to get
them if you understand what i'm saying
i wouldn't be shocked i'm not saying it
happened but it certainly wouldn't be
shocking to me
um johann sis says this year's october
surprise will be the q3 market results
my feeling is they will be pretty bad
but if not
trump will win i don't know about market
i think you mean
do you mean gdp i'm guessing you mean
gdp and if you do
yes i've been predicting that for some
time we have 10 seconds left to finish
out a level 5 hype train
i think we're going to fail to do it
only five seconds left
that's sad we almost made it we almost
made it
very very close that's unfortunate um
matthew paul is agreeing with me saying
it might be in bad taste but of all the
presidents we've had trump seems the
most statistically likely to have had
under the table abortions in his past
100
agree 100 agree with you
um incomplete joker says say what you do
and blame others classic republican
tactics switch republicans with
democrats and you'll get the truth
in these speeches yeah everything is
opposite
it's opposite constantly in these
speeches you're absolutely right
let's see who's up next i'm guessing
we'll have some of these propaganda
montages coming up soon here is one
about um women voting presumably
zachary ezioni says will you debate at
politicon
i can't imagine politicon is even going
on
uh let's see let me google that
politicon um
yeah there's nothing uh there's nothing
i can't imagine politicons happening for
a while someday i will tell the story
of why i was not at the last politicon
and it is a hell of a story
it is a hell of a story that would shock
and appall
uh anyone with any sense of reason or
rationality
but that's a story for a different day
that's not that's not for today
let me say thank you to shannon marshall
who is new member number 21 on my
website today
and daniel andre kroger is new member
number 22.
greg speth is 23 and rich hussein
is number 24. we actually might get to
56 today
which is the goal we're off to just a
blazing f fast start
semi truck driver says now it makes
sense that the wack pack loves trump
yeah a surprisingly high number of
howard stern whack packers
seem to like donald trump and
it all sort of fits together in some way
right i mean i don't think that that's
shocking uh to to too many of us
um dare attend with a very aggressive
super chat you guys can read this one
for yourselves it's a little bit
aggressive and there could be uh there
could be kids watching so i'm not gonna
read this one
in fact i know that there are lots of
kids watching today but that's an
aggressive one
and i'm not saying i disagree by the way
at all
but i'm just not i'm going to opt out of
reading that one
out loud i would love to hear via super
chat or in messages with your twitch
subscriptions
how are you planning to vote in other
words what is your plan
are you just saying i'm voting in person
i'm gonna wear seven masks and a
beekeeper's outfit
and i'm just gonna do it or are you
doing uh
vote by mail and mailing it are you
doing vote by mail and sending it in
i'm sorry dropping it off what is your
plan as far as that goes
thanks to the most wise one for gifting
five subscriptions over on twitch
getting us very close to 1400
blue montserrat asks if i was not at
politicon the last time because i was
afraid of debating jessie lee peterson
no that's not the reason why that's not
the reason why
jason nadal says shout out to katie for
being an awesome girlfriend can you
please get me a peanut butter popsicle
from the freezer i love you
katie that sounds like a polite request
i would do it
uh a ritual pathak says i'm moving
somewhere near diesel cafe
yay okay congratulations
chef's pawn says doesn't this feel like
karma for trump and punishment for us
that he criticized former presidents for
handling certain situations
and now he's dealing with all of those
himself at once
well said let's listen to kaylee
maganani tested positive for the bracha
ii genetic mutation
a mutation that put my chances of breast
cancer
at 84 percent it was the same mutation
that my mom had
compelling her to get a preventative
double mastectomy
removing her breast tissue but
protecting her
from a disease that has taken far too
many
of our mothers our sisters
our friends in my family
eight women alone were diagnosed with
breast cancer several in their young
twenties
i now faced the same prospect
for nearly a decade i was routinely at
moffitt cancer center
getting mris ultrasounds and necessary
surveillance during these visits
i crossed paths with brave women
battling cancer
and fighting through chemotherapy they
were a testament to american strength
they are american heroes
on may 1st 2018
i followed in my mother's footsteps
choosing to get a preventative
mastectomy
i was scared the night before i fought
back tears
as i prepared to lose a piece of myself
forever
but the next day with my mom
dad husband i can tell you that this
president stands by americans with
pre-existing conditions
in fact president trump called me this
morning i spoke with him
several times today and he told me how
proud he was of me
for sharing this story the same way
president trump has supported me
he supports you i see it every day
see now is where it goes into nonsense
heard him say the hardest part of his
job
is writing to loved ones of fallen
soldiers trump writes
i've seen him offer heartfelt outreach
to grieving parents who lost their
children
to crime in the streets and i've watched
him fight for americans
who lost their jobs president trump
fights for the american people because
he cares about stories like these
i have a nine-month-old daughter she's a
beautiful
sweet little girl and i choose
to work for this president for her
when i look into my baby's eyes i see a
new life
a miracle for which i have a solemn
responsibility
to protect that means protecting
america's future
a future president trump will fight for
where our neighborhoods are protected
where life
is sacred where god is cherished
not taken out of our schools removed
from our pledge
and erased from our history why would
god be in public schools that doesn't
that doesn't make sense legally
to grow up in president donald j trump's
america
choosing to have a preventative
mastectomy was the hardest decision
i ever had to make but supporting
president trump who will protect my
daughter
and our children's future was the
easiest
okay
continuing towards tonight's keynote
which is of course
vice president mike pence who will
formally accept his
renomination um and this is
uh karen pence okay my husband is vice
president mike pence
one hundred years ago today the 19th
amendment
was adopted into the united states
constitution
guaranteeing women the right to vote
because of heroes like susan b anthony
and lucy stone
women today like our daughters audrey
and charlotte
and future generations will have their
voices heard
and their votes count the women's
suffrage movement
was the gateway that led to women having
the opportunities
to achieve monumental milestones and
accomplish significant achievements
in both civic and governmental roles
this evening we look at heroes
in our land as second lady of the united
states for the past three and a half
years
i have had the honor of meeting many
heroes across this great country
the pence's are a military family
our son michael serves in the united
states marines
and our son-in-law henry serves in the
u.s navy
and one of my key initiatives is to
elevate and encourage
military spouses these men and women
like our daughter charlotte and our
daughter-in-law sarah
are the home front heroes i have been
privileged to hear so many stories
of selfless support volunteer spirit
and great contributions to the armed
forces
and our communities you know military
spouses may experience
swallows and job changes periods of
being a single parent while their loved
one is deployed
all while exhibiting pride strength
and determination and being a part of
something bigger than themselves
to all of the military spouses thank you
president trump and vice president pence
have been supporting
our united states armed forces including
our military families on a significant
scale
while traveling throughout our nation to
educate military spouses
about policy solutions that president
trump has promoted
involving real tangible progress
in military spouse employment i have
been inspired
to meet heroes like lisa bradley
and cameron cruz these military spouses
decided to start their own business are
riveter
named after the rosie the riveter
campaign used to recruit women workers
during world war
ii our riveter makes beautiful handbags
designed and manufactured exclusively
by military spouses and many of those
spouses
live all over the country they prepare
and send their section of the bags
to the company located in north carolina
where the final product is assembled
what does this have to do with voting
for trump
military spouse hero jalon hal johnson
in billings montana is a culinary artist
who had dreamed of starting her own
restaurant
working with the small business
administration's development center
jalon started her restaurant the sassy
biscuit
is this sponsored content opened a
second restaurant
in dover new hampshire and as the second
lady
i've also been able to bring awareness
to a form of therapy
for our heroic veterans suffering from
ptsd
art therapy facilitated by a
professional art therapist
is especially effective with
post-traumatic stress disorder
master gunnery sergeant christo a marine
veteran i met in tampa
who deployed for combat in iraq and
afghanistan
said nothing had helped him deal with
the trauma from his service in the
marines
until he finally agreed to meet with the
art therapist
at walter reed medical center
chris credits art therapy with saving
his marriage and his life
and chris went on to establish a
glassblowing workshop to help other vets
what saved her marriage i wonder veteran
heroes
struggle as they transition back into
civilian life
and sometimes the stress is too
difficult to manage alone
a few weeks ago i had the honor of
speaking with some amazing americans who
answer
the veterans crisis line one in
particular
sydney morgan especially impacted me
a veteran herself sydney said it is the
highest
honor of her life until they physically
walk into a clinic to receive help they
deserve
and she can pass their hand to someone
ready to help
in these difficult times we've all seen
so many examples of everyday americans
reaching out to those in need those who
in humility have considered others more
important than themselves
we've seen health care workers teachers
first responders mental health providers
law enforcement officers grocery and
delivery workers
and farmers and so many others
heroes all
one hundred years ago did you hear that
when she paused somebody yelled
something in the background it's really
weird
vote america let's honor our heroes
let's
reelect president trump and vice
president pence
for four more years god bless our heroes
and god bless the united states
of america
was really weird guys we hold these
truths to be self-evident
hey just for a little maybe comedic
interlude during the propaganda
i posted this to my instagram yesterday
i want to get your thoughts as to
whether you think this is real this is
an email that i got
um oh by the way if people really want
something
to to just cool off here's me with a
puppy that's
just a beautiful image but this is what
i posted yesterday how many of you think
this is real
um hold on let me zoom it out a little
bit
hello david pakman misspelled so many
people state the republican party is
white
so it was important for those to state
their ethnicity referring yesterday to
why people
why people were referring to their being
black
just like the demon rats donald trump
does need four more years to fix
what the bushes clintons and obamas did
to this country on top of all the bs
they do to get in his way
a vote for joe biden will put our
children at risk
read the constitution of this country
i'm watching you bash our president
right now as i'm writing this you're
sick i hope
you get well soon don't forget you can
always buy a plane
ticket i prefer whole wheat everything
but some people just like playing others
like sesame
you can buy a plane ticket trump 2020 as
you can see anthony mellen fantano
in the uh chat saying a plane ticket
sounds nice right now do you guys think
that's real or is that a troll let me
know what you think
household of all women they were
self-reliant
and resilient their lives were not
easy but they never complained
money was tight but we had an abundance
of what mattered most
family faith and freedom
i learned that in america limited means
does not make for limited dreams the
promise of america
belongs to us all this is a land
of inventors and innovators of
entrepreneurs and educators
of pioneers and parents each
contributing to the success
and the future of a great nation
and her people these everyday heroes
have a champion in president trump
the teacher who took extra time to help
students adjust
to months of virtual learning the nurse
who finished a 12-hour coveted shift
and then took a brief break only to
change her mask
gown and gloves to do it all over again
the small business owner striving to
reopen
after the lockdown was lifted and then
again
after her store was vandalized and
looted
the single mom with two kids two jobs
two commutes who ten years after that
empty promise
finally has health insurance
president trump and vice president pence
have lifted americans
provided them with dignity opportunity
dignity
and results i have seen try traveling to
another country see how much dignity you
feel you have as an american right now
and encouraging a child who has lost a
parent
a parent who has lost a child
a worker who lost his job
an adolescent who lost her way to drugs
don't lose hope he has told them
assuring them that they are not alone
and that they matter there always
will be people who have far more than us
our responsibility is to focus on those
who have far less than us president
trump has done precisely that in taking
unprecedented action
to combat this nation's drug crisis he
told me
this is so important kellyanne so many
lives have been ruined by addiction
and will never even know it because
people are ashamed to reach out for help
and they're not even sure who to turn to
in their time i can guarantee you trump
didn't say that to kellyanne
look the other way president trump
stared directly at this drug crisis next
door
and through landmark bipartisan
legislation has helped secure
historic investments in surveillance
interdiction
education prevention treatment and
recovery
we have a long way to go but the
political inertia
that cost lives and the silence and the
stigma
that prevents people in need from coming
forward
is melting away this is the man i know
and the president we need for four more
years
he picks the toughest fights and tackles
the most complex problems
he has stood by me and he will stand
up for you in honor of the women who
empowered me
and for the future of the children we
all cherish
thank you and god bless you always
strange speech and as many of you know
kellyanne conway down just to her last
five days as part of the trump
administration she will be leaving the
white house her husband
uh george conway will be uh leaving
twitter in the lincoln project
and things are not very good right now
for the
conway family that i can very very much
assure you let me get caught up on new
member thank yous i don't want to fall
behind and then i want to do super chat
so this is a good time to get those in
new member number 25 today is hannah
simpson number 26
is michael posey number 27 is ray olson
abigail paul is number 28 mcduffie just
signed up on my website and
is number 29 brooke saunders is number
30 drake anderson is 31
tristan henry is 32 and katherine
lavallee
is new member number 33 today we hit 56
that's the rnc high
on monday and that's our target today
okay let's see what's on people's minds
hardwood says it's funny that
kellyanne's husband is actively trying
to get trump out and is now an
independent it must be weird for her
yeah who knows what's going on um at in
their house
i wanted to address this patty asks
please excuse my ignorance david but
where would one go to follow the poll
numbers do i go to different news
outlets
the the best place in my mind is real
clear politics real clear politics
will show you all of the different
polling it'll show you an average
you can then look at individual polls
state polls national
etc etc that's the way to uh the way to
go
um what else oh bowser
says trump called for him and biden to
do a drug test wow yeah
trump said that he wants him he will
submit to a drug test but he also wants
biden drug tested before the debate
because trump believes biden was using
some kind of performance-enhancing drugs
before the bernie debate that that's the
only way biden could have performed so
well
i'm not this is for real it's not uh
it's it's not a joke
thanks to pseudospike for subscribing on
twitch with the message
kellyanne quit because her daughter
hates her
not all together wrong not all together
wrong
heiken is sex says what is it with these
republican women
stone cold eyes trying to look emphatic
they just look weird pop stackles
says remember there's a category 4
hurricane hitting louisiana right now
there is the husks network says really
trying to look like
saints with a nun yeah they're certainly
pandering to the more religious crowd
um remember i mean if you care about a
more religious candidate joe biden
really is a catholic
and donald trump is not religious so
that's something if that matters to you
certainly something i would keep in mind
let's take
uh let's take a listen to what she's
saying i have to say may be difficult
for some to hear
i am saying it because i'm not just
pro-life
i'm pro-eternal life and i want all of
us to end up in heaven together someday
brings me to why i'm here today
donald trump is the most pro-life
president that this nation has
ever had defending life at all stages
his belief in the sanctity of life
transcends politics trump clearly is
fine with abortion but he's just at 68
years old decided he has to be against
it to run as a republican
presidential ticket ever even supporting
the horrors of late term
abortion and infanticide because of his
courage and conviction
president trump has earned the support
of america's pro-life community
moreover he has a nationwide of
religious standing behind him
you'll find us here with our weapon of
choice the rosary
so thank you mr president we are all
praying for you
[Music]
okay so there we have that david
mclaughlin with a very edgy
message saying david you should do the
stream shirtless to give your gay fans
something better to pay attention to
instead of these liars
why would that only be for my gay fans
what about the heterosexual women in the
audience or do you assume that there are
none
it's kind of an unusual message thanks
to volt
jamie for subscribing with twitch prime
uh phys ed says biden should ask for
trump's taxes in exchange of the drug
test i like that
la laker says i liked the coke fueled
circus from day one these past two
nights have been incredibly tedious
night one was definitely the most um
boisterous certainly the most boisterous
oh people want to hear from lou holtz
okay any obstacles
and always remember that in this great
country of ours
anyone can amount to something special
i live by those principles of hard work
and responsibility my whole life
living out the american story and it
works
but there are people today like
politicians
professors protesters and of course
president trump's naysayers in the media
who like to blame others for problems
they don't have pride in our country
and because they no longer ask what can
i do for my country
only what the country should be doing
for them they don't have pride
in themselves that's wrong
when i was an officer in the army i
served with so many great americans
to embrace their responsibility to our
country
i'm so proud of their sacrifices and the
opportunity it has provided
for so many millions america remains a
land of opportunity
no matter what the other side says or
believes
you know there's a statue of me at notre
dame
i guess they needed a place for the
pigeons to land
but if you look closely you will see
these three words there
trust commitment and love all my
life i've made my choices based on these
three words
i used these three rules to make choices
about everything
my beloved wife of 59 years athletes i
coached and of course politicians
even president trump i ask myself three
things
one can i trust them when a leader tells
you something
you got to be able to count on it that's
president
trump he says what he means he means
what he says
and he's done what he said he would do
no at every single turn
wrong one of the important reasons he
has my trust
is because nobody is better stronger
never mind for the unborn
than president trump the biden harris
ticket
is the most radically pro-abortion
campaign in history
they and other politicians are catholics
in name only and abandon innocent lives
president trump protects those lives
i trust president trump the second
question i ask
is are they committed to doing their
very
best president trump always finds a way
to get something done
if you want to do something bad enough
you will find a way
if not you'll find an excuse and excuses
are a lot easier to find than solutions
president trump finds solutions
president trump
is committed and the third question i
ask
is do they love people do they care
about others
to me this is very clear president trump
has demonstrated
through his prison reform advocating for
school choice
and welfare reform okay so this is the
view of a former
football coach i think we sort of
understand that
piece um francisco padilla asks david
any chance we can get a buff david meme
to help get us through this also can you
say hi to ness
we love your show uh yeah i could
probably pull up the
buff david deep fake let me see if i can
find it here
um it's actually a little bit
difficult to find buff david yeah that's
a tough one
uh okay i think i got it let me see here
yeah we do need a little bit of comic
relief it's getting a little ugly
there it is that's bearded buff david
six-pack man that's me after i leave the
gym
on leg day
yep there it is cool
all right uh we're going to continue
with uh
we're going to continue with super chats
alan glynn says hope gullible
old lou doesn't watch those tom selleck
commercials or he'll be homeless next
uh do we want to listen to this
gentleman michael mickel
nick michael mchale i'm sorry the
closed captioning was deceptive there
people want to hear from this guy okay
association of police organizations
napo our organization recently endorsed
donald trump
for re-election as president of the
united states
our endorsement recognized his strong
support
for the men and women on the front lines
particularly during these challenging
times
we value his support of aggressive
federal
prosecution of those who attack our
police officers
his signing of the law enforcement
mental health and wellness act
and his support for permanently
authorizing funds
to support 911 i actually used to have
like a high and tight flat top
it was a while ago but there was one or
two times there were there were some
instances where i asked for it
at the hairdresser it was it was
different they do so
willingly to protect our families and
communities
i'm proud that the overwhelming majority
of
american police officers are the best of
the best
and put their lives on the line without
hesitation
and good officers need to know their
elected leaders
and the department brass have their
backs unfortunately
chaos results when failed officials
in cities like portland minneapolis
chicago and new york make the conscious
decision
not to support law enforcement i think
we get the idea this is definitely not
what i would consider like a top tier
speech of the evening so i want to keep
hearing from uh
hearing from you guys um some people
asking where we are from the standpoint
of a million subscribers uh everything
is still going
fine um i'll let's look at if we have an
updated
projection to make very important
projection um
october 13th so it's it's come up
another couple of days we are estimated
to hit
one million youtube subscribers which is
just gonna be a massive accomplishment
i'm gonna be totally honest with you
guys uh even though we're still about
uh what is that about a month and a half
away from when we're slated to hit and
by the way you
if you're watching on youtube you can
help me by hitting subscribe right now
we are already working on a sort of
congratulations david and friends
congratulations on a million and we have
some great people that i think you're
gonna enjoy hearing from
uh cutting videos oh and austin show
yeah i at austin show you you replied to
my twitter dm
yeah austin you got to get me the video
okay please uh
we we don't want things to get ugly here
but um there's going to be a lot of
people
people some people you like some people
you don't like who are going to be
featured
in this compilation um that we are
putting together for the million
subscriber day it's gonna be a huge huge
day
and austin please please get me that
video
or you're just gonna be out that's it
austin might be out and then it's over
okay nora baca asks if everyone took a
quaalude before speaking tonight i
listen i don't know what drugs people
are on during these things i wish i knew
more about what drugs are even available
dit says if i had to summarize the rnc
day one equals high and raving mad
day two hostage video vives day three
statues
i agree with that i agree with that
maeve jack
watches this 40 minutes behind so that
they can skip the chunks of cringe
oh let's listen to elise stefanik she's
a bomb throwing nut
in revolution it's where almost 250
years ago
brave patriots fought her face is almost
a recognizable from from what it looked
like during the impeachment hearings
it's incredible
it's where 40 years ago in lake placid a
team of amateur hockey players
out-hustled out-skated and defeated the
soviet union
stunning the world and giving us the
unforgettable
miracle on ice and today it's home to
fort drum
and the historic 10th mountain division
the u.s once did well in olympic hockey
so we should re-elect trump
eleven where i saw firsthand president
trump
graciously thank and honor our men and
women in uniform
and sign the largest pay raise for our
troops in a decade
since our nation's founding generation
after generation
of everyday americans served and
sacrificed to preserve and strengthen
the american dream the vision of life
liberty and the pursuit
of happiness and the idea that if you
work hard
and dream big you can achieve anything
you imagine
hey i don't want to focus on something
so irrelevant but
the flags look really cheap they look
like thin fabric that's wrinkled like if
it
their whole thing is all about flags and
the flags look
piss-poor my immediate family to
graduate from college
ran for congress to serve upstate new
york and am proudly
the youngest republican woman elected to
congress in history
i am honored to support president trump
for re-election
because i know that he is the only
candidate who
will stand up for hard-working families
and protect the american dream
for future generations since his first
day
in office president trump has fought
tirelessly
to deliver results for all americans
despite the democrats
baseless and illegal impeachment sham
and the media's endless obsession with
it
i was proud to lead the effort standing
up for the constitution
president trump and most importantly the
american people
this attack was not just on the
president it was an attack on you
your voice and your vote hey what is she
talking about
we're not swayed by these partisan
attacks our support for president trump
is
stronger than ever before we know what's
at stake in this historic election
americans from all walks of life are
unified in support of our president
it's why more republican women than ever
are running for office this year
we understand that this election is a
choice between the far left
democratic socialist agenda versus
protecting and preserving
the american dream president trump is
working to safely reopen
our main street economy he understands
that the engine of our country
is fueled by the ingenuity and
determination of american workers
entrepreneurs and small businesses joe
biden
wants to keep them locked up in the
basement and crush them
with four trillion dollars in new taxes
we face remember biden said no no tax
increases on anybody earning under
400k of the past 47 years
or president trump who will stand up for
the american people
and the constitution i believe in the
wisdom and spirit of the american people
to elect the only candidate who is
capable of protecting
the american dream oh she's switching
donald j
trump thank you to the north country for
the opportunity to serve as your voice
supporting his re-election god bless the
united states of america
the greatest country on earth
all right so there is congresswoman
elise stefanik with
maybe the most impassioned and
belligerently delusional speech of the
evening
so far um and we are going to
uh continue hearing from a number of
different people throughout
uh do pete let's listen to madison
cawthorne he's been become a little bit
of a
republican celebrity lately i know
something about adversity
at 18 years old i was in a horrific car
accident that's left me paralyzed from
the weight it's waist down
instantly my hopes and dreams were
seemingly destroyed
i was given a one percent chance of
surviving but
thanks to the power of prayer a very
loving community and many skilled
doctors
i made it it took me over a year to
recover
my first public outing in a wheelchair
was to a professional baseball game
you know before my accident i was six
foot three i stood out in a crowd
but as i wheeled through the stadium i
felt invisible
at 20 i thought about giving up
however i knew i could still make a
difference
you know my accident has given me new
eyes to see
and new ears to hear god protected my
mind
and my ability to speak so i say to
people who feel forgotten
ignored and invisible i see you
i hear you at 20
i made a choice in 2020 our country has
a choice
we can give up on the american idea or
we can work together
to make our imperfect union more perfect
i choose to fight for the future to
seize the high ground and retake the
shining city on a hill
while the radical left wants to
dismantle to fund and destroy
here we go republicans under president
trump's leadership want to rebuild
restore and renew i just turned 25.
when i'm elected this november i'll be
the youngest member of congress
in over 200 years and if you don't think
young people can change the world
then you just don't know american
history george washington was 21 when he
received his first military commission
abe lincoln 22 when he first ran for
office and my personal favorite james
madison was just
25 years old when he signed the
declaration of independence
in times of peril young people have
stepped up and saved this country abroad
and at home
we held the line scaled the cliffs
crossed oceans
liberated camps and cracked codes
yet today political forces want to usher
in the digital dark ages
a time of information without wisdom and
tribalism without truth
leaders on the left have normalized
emotion-based voting
and a radicalized identity politics that
rejects martin luther king's dream
mlk's dream i have to tell you we've
seen way more identity politics during
the rnc than the dnc
character millions of people risk their
lives every year to come here because
they believe in the dream of mlk
and the american dream join
us as we the party of freedom double
down
on ensuring the american dream for all
people
we are committed to building a new town
square it welcomes all ideas and all
people
here we will have freedom of speech not
freedom from speech
to liberals i say let's have a
conversation
be a true liberal listen to other ideas
and let the best ones prevail
and to conservatives i say let's define
what we support
and win the argument in areas like
health care on the environment
in this new town square you don't have
to apologize for your beliefs
or cower to a mob you can kneel before
god but
stand for our flag the american idea
my ancestors fought for during the
revolutionary war
is just as exciting and revolutionary
today as it was 250 years ago
i say to americans who love our country
young and old
be a radical for freedom oh guys be a
radical
for liberty and be a radical
for our republic for which i stand
one nation under god with liberty and
justice for all
thank you and may god bless america
[Music]
okay um
i mean i guess my reaction is
he didn't really make the case to vote
for trump
you know i i think that's where i would
sort of
leave the focus um i do want to get to a
few super chats so while uh we we
continue to dip in and out of the
different
um speakers i
uh let's see here um eris kitarelli
says hey david can you give a shout out
to my father-in-law john whitehouse jr
he got me to subscribe to you and he
loves your channel and show yes
john thank you thank you for getting
eris sky tally to sign up for my program
i very much appreciate it
chicken head picnelli says would someone
please iron the flags i just don't want
to iron them
okay gizmatic okay
so tired of them invoking mlk yeah
they're invoking mlk for the opposite
reason
that mlk should be invoked they they in
fact
uh we can't i can't even do the mlk
stuff
uh wait a second aaron greene this is
like a danny mcbride comedy
oh some people want to listen to this do
people want to listen to this or not
all right well listen a little it has no
resemblance to president trump
and i'm fed up with the way he's
portrayed in the media
who refused to acknowledge what he's
actually done for the black community
it's confusing the minds of our innocent
children
before i left to come deliver this
message my energetic
eight-year-old son jackson stopped me
and said dad
can you please just tell everyone that
all
lives need to matter and that god loves
everyone
okay yeah people actually don't really
seem to want this one so we're we'll get
away from that
uh sandy says i wonder what they think
martin luther king would feel about
confederate flags
yeah uh i've not heard that asked
but i think that it's a perfectly
reasonable question
um thanks to mercenary for subscribing
over on twitch as well as
cherry ac and bourbon volt
jamie james jamie and sudo spike
we are officially at 1400 twitch
subscribers
that is a new we have breached 1400
i have never achieved 1400 before
and that is a great number to be at
chakaseki says david could you give a
shout out to my homeboy ryan b
in boston he's an expecting father
ryan shout out to you good luck
and uh sounds like you're going to have
your hands full
very very soon jeffrey geltman says i
can't wait to see i can't i guess you
mean i can't wait to see mike pence
malfunction in front of the entire
country
i don't think meg pence will malfunction
but you just won't be able to tell the
difference
and dennis vardy says thanks for all you
do david i appreciate that as well
thank you i know i missed some super
chat so let's just scroll up and pick a
random one
those i got let's see what we've got
um keith jacobs is going to be voting in
person
how do your number of viewers between
the dnc and rnc live coverage compare
sadly trump is up and biden is down in
recent polls
so i'm getting more viewership during
the rnc than i got
during the dnc from the standpoint of
live
but the tv ratings seem to be down
during the rnc relative to the dnc so
make of that make of that what you will
um let's see here
the defense says i can feel all of my
brain cells make
melting away as these people speak yeah
i
estimate i lost six iq points on monday
three of them when kimberly guilfoyle
was screaming
and i did some things on tuesday to
recover them back which i'm not even
going to bore you with but i i feel like
i do have them back
mike boudreau says i would like somebody
to troll the convention and say don't
vote for trump
we don't even know if this stuff is live
and if and the stuff that is live i'm
sure is on a delay so i
it would they would never get out
someone would dump it i don't think we
would get it
jonathan mccartney says how can trumpus
be deprogrammed once this farce is over
beautiful question let's deal with it
when this is over
let's deal with it when uh when when
this is over
um and it's it's a difficult question as
well
i'm not pretending that that it's an
easy one
joseph dempsey says hey david love the
stream and the show
it's terrible but u.s politics is like a
soap opera and i can't look away
can it be fixed anytime soon no even if
biden wins it's going to be a while
um there's no no doubt about that none
of these little montages where trump
meets with workers have been used
tonight
um and
it's sort of surprising because i think
trump thinks they went really well
obviously they didn't okay let's listen
to what this is about
when i spoke out against
china's one child policy and other
injustices i was prosecuted
beaten sent to prison
and putin this is another one of those
like because
bad things happen in china or like they
could bring a north korean defector
that's terrible but it doesn't mean we
should vote for trump
i think in fact trump is more like the
leaders of china and north korea
than anybody i want in the oval office
can embassy
in beijing i'm forever
grateful to the american people
for welcome me and my family
to the united states where
we are now free the ccp
is an enemy of humanity
it is terrorizing its own
people and it is threatening
the well-being of the world
in china expressing beliefs
or ideas not approved by the ccp
religion democracy see what's crazy
about this
is trump is more enamored with president
xi kim jong-un
erdogan putin
you understand than any president we've
had in a very long time so
the idea of this to draw a contrast that
says we should vote trump it's like no
this is a reminder
trump was impressed that she set it up
so now he can be president indefinitely
this is a reminder we shouldn't vote
trump
they don't get why why am i bothering
they don't get it
led on these and we need
the other countries to join him
in this fight a fight for
our future stand
up to fight unfairness
isn't easy i know so
there's president trump but he has
showing the courage to reach that
fight we need to support
vote and fight for president trump
for the sake of the world
thank you slick pinstripe suit i have to
tell you
uh that is a that is a nice looking suit
on this guy
although the message seems very
counterproductive here is congressman
lee zeldin
america as a land of heroes i'm here
at a vfw post of heroes in west hampton
beach new york
i've seen amazing americans in action
raised in a law enforcement family
deployed to iraq as an 82nd airborne
paratrooper
and serving today in the army reserve my
generation
of post-911 veterans has huge shoes to
fill
following our greatest generation that
fought tyranny
and save the world all over our country
everyday heroes serve and sacrifice for
the greater good
farmers truckers craftsmen these heroes
keep america running and president trump
fights for them every day this year
we've especially relied on one
particular group of heroes
frontline medical workers my twin
daughters michael and ariana
were born over 14 weeks early they
weighed just a pound and a half
at two weeks michaela went into septic
shock
had a stroke and underwent brain surgery
leaving a third of the left side of her
brain a whole
her doctors didn't believe michaela
would survive
fearing dire permanent consequences even
if she did
through the miracles of modern medicine
power of prayer
and her will to live my daughters are
now starting high school
and doing great with no long-term
effects
from those frightful months in the nicu
so when i learned my county's ppe
stockpile
was depleted i immediately thought of
those healthcare workers
who saved my baby girls jared kushner
and i were on the phone
late into that saturday night the very
next day
president trump announced he was sending
us two hundred thousand n95 masks
he actually delivered almost four
hundred thousand
that number quickly grew to 1.2 million
yeah
the numbers grow more quickly than fedex
can fly around which is weird
thousands of ventilators to new york he
deployed the uss
comfort and converted the javits center
to a field hospital
his administration authorized our lab
testing requests
at blinding speed during a once in a
century pandemic
and unforeseeable crisis sent to us from
a faraway land
the president's effort for new york was
phenomenal
for our nation to emerge even stronger
more prosperous freer and more secure
than ever
to make our country greater than ever
before
we must reelect president trump
we are the land of the free because of
the brave
and we are the land of opportunity
because we have a president
who wants to empower the best of who we
are to be the best of what we can be
there's never been a nation greater than
ours
never a people more resilient than ours
and never a future for america more
promising than ours
right now keeping america great
is up to us and losing
is not an option
[Music]
um that speech was particularly devoid
of anything i mean it's like it was just
so generic in nature it was just there's
nothing there
there's no there there i think is the
way i would say it
um let me thank a few people who signed
up on my website because i don't want to
keep falling behind on that
new member number 30 4
is miracle banks new member number 35 is
bill
twoson tanya lee is new member number 36
christy coleman is number 37 and lindsay
johns
is number 38 we may actually get to 56
which was where we were on monday
i have a pretty good feeling we still
have more than an hour to go
um okay let's uh continue on here
viola spice says it's entertaining
watching right wing hypocrisy
at its prime half of the people speaking
at the rnc
stutter and they don't any sense i guess
you mean they don't
make any sense when speaking um
yeah i'm trying to focus more on the
content really than the deliveries
deretend says trump only delivers ppe if
he can throw it at them right like when
he went to puerto rico
and shot rolls of toilet paper toilet uh
paper towels
it's not really ppe but i understand
what what you're saying
john kovach points out still no hazard
pay for essential workers
um what else do we have
w pooh says gary locke who's a democrat
rescued him out of china but he's now
endorsing shooting border crosser on
twitter
uh that i didn't see oh joni ernst i did
want to see what kind of lunatic things
she came up with
college then dedicated my life to
serving my country
as a local official a battalion
commander in the military
and as a us senator did she say she was
an italian commander oh battalion
it's a mission a way of life
it's what brought me to cedar rapids
iowa in 2008 when i was in the national
guard
we saw historic floods that swept
through the communities
we lent a helping hand to our fellow
iowans
who were literally under water we
thought we had seen the worst
but 12 years later these same
communities have faced
an even more devastating disaster the
recent deracho
storm if you don't live in iowa
you may not have heard much about it at
first while reporters here in the state
were in the trenches
covering the equivalent of a category 2
hurricane
most of the national media looked the
other way
to them iowa's still just fly over
country
houses farms were destroyed
about one-third of our crops here were
damaged
in some cases these storms wiped out a
lifetime of work
and yet iowa farmers didn't hesitate to
grab their chainsaws and check on their
neighbors
our farmers live every day with that
sense of service
the stewards of the land the ones who
feed
and fuel the world president trump
quickly signed an emergency declaration
for iowa to provide relief
and of course when president trump came
to cedar rapids
the national media finally did too
for years i've worked closely with the
president for farmers in iowa
and across the country we scrapped obama
and biden's punishing waters of the
united states rule
which would have regulated about 97
percent of land in
iowa in some cases even puddles
it would have been a nightmare for
farmers
the president delivered on major trade
deals with japan
and the united states mexico canada
agreement
and that last one was where trump didn't
know where to sign
fuel year-round that means more choices
for you at the pump
and more jobs for farmers in the
heartland
this is something the obama biden
administration failed to do
in eight years in fact i can't recall an
administration more hostile to farmers
than obama biden
unless you count the biden-harris ticket
the democratic party of joe biden is
pushing this so-called green new deal
if given power they would essentially
ban
animal agriculture and eliminate
gas-powered cars
of course that's completely untrue um
gas powered cars i mean listen every
country
is setting targets for getting out you
know off of internal combustion engines
and over to electric
um the idea that they're going to ban
agriculture
is ridiculous you know these are just
flat out lies and fear-mongering that i
hope doesn't work on anybody it's crazy
they're going to ban they're going to
end the suburbs they're going to end
cows they're going to end everything and
economic growth
under a trump pence administration or
the biden harris path paved by liberal
coastal elites and radical
environmentalists
an america where farmers are punished
jobs are destroyed
and taxes crush the middle class
that is our choice and it's a clear one
this might be crazier than elise
stefanik's speech
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen i'm burgess owens
shackled in the belly of a slave ship an
eight-year-old boy
named silas burgess came to america to
be sold on an auction block
by the grace of god and the courage of
slaves who believed in freedom
sal's escaped through the underground
railroad and settled in the great state
of texas
he will only become a successful
entrepreneur he built his community's
first church
first elementary school and purchased
102 acres of farmland which he paid off
in two years
i'm here today a candidate for congress
because of my great great grandfather
silas burgess i was raised in the south
during the days of jim crow and the kkk
even through the challenges of
segregation we were taught that
anything is possible in america when i
was 22 years old
i thought all my dreams had come true
when i was drafted by the new york jets
ten years later with a pro bowl nod and
a super bowl championship under my belt
i left the nfl to start a business i
thought i could never fail
but years later i did and i lost
everything
as i moved my family of six into a
one-bedroom basement apartment in
brooklyn new york
i had a choice that was weird the closed
captions said baseball apartment
work i worked as a chimney sweep during
the day
in a security guard at night it was
humbling to be recognized cleaning a
chimney by someone who once cheered me
as a nfl fan but those hard days would
pay off
and eventually i started a career
rewarding career in the corporate world
we live in a country we're encouraged to
dream big
where second chances are at the core of
our american dna
we don't hear that same message from
nancy pelosi's congress
career politicians elitists and even a
former bartender
one of us to believe it's impossible
they want us to believe that what i did
what my great great grandfather did it's
weird how they complain about coastal
elites being
you know condescending and then they
keep making fun of
aoc having been a bartender right it's
like they just don't get it members
of congress promotes the same socialism
that my father fought against in world
war ii
we have a democratic candidate for
president who says that i'm not black
if i don't vote for him now more than
ever
we need leaders who stand by their
principles and won't compromise their
values for political opportunities
now more than ever many leaders will
stand up to the lawlessness
supported by the radical left this
november
we have an opportunity to reject the mob
mentality
and once again be the america that my
great great grandfather believed in
during the trump administration business
ownership among blacks hispanics and
females
have reached all-time highs those same
groups
enjoyed record low unemployment and
unprecedented prosperity
and we're just getting started i'm
running for congress
because we don't need more career
politicians we need a few more
chimney sweeps we need more leaders like
president trump
who understand the freedoms that make up
the fabric of america
my fellow americans specifically my
democrat and
independent friends it is now time for
us to unite
and put aside partisan barriers help us
win back the house
keep the senate and give our president
four more years
and i promise you we will make you proud
thank you and god bless the united
states of america
so a very um sort of out of touch
speech uh floating in from from nowhere
i do want to hear what people are saying
and if you want to get your message up
to my left at the bottom left of the
screen those are youtube super chats and
if you're watching on youtube you can
send those in
for example derek miller just sent one
in saying
god god god maybe they should all stop
talking and just go home and pray for
trump to win that would work right
jonathan mccartney says realizing that
we are not there yet
and could still avoid reaching it have
you defined a certain point at which you
would consider fleeing the country for
your own protection
it has to have crossed your mind yeah i
have a clip about it a week or two ago
um i i have a clip on my youtube channel
about exactly that and listen
i mean it's like my life is in the
united states now so it would really
it would take more than just trump
winning for me to leave but there's no
doubt that
um if trump were to win i would
definitely
look at doing some extended remote work
type of things
if uh if coronavirus normalizes
maybe in argentina where i was born and
have family um
it's something that's kind of always on
the back burner like it would be great
to it would be great to just work from
there for six months i think trump being
re-elected would be sort of the perfect
incentive to do it so i'm certainly
certainly thinking about that
and cost of living extraordinarily low
there oliver wilde says i thought the
military wasn't supposed to be
politicized i would never salute trump
not because i disrespect the office of
the president
but because he does well said
ragnarok says more chimney sweeps
less bartenders that's fewer bartenders
as we go now to lara trump mother to
luke and carolina
and the daughter-in-law of our 45th
president
donald j trump but tonight i come to you
simply as an american my life began like
many in our country
i grew up in wrightsville beach north
carolina my parents were small business
owners and worked hard to make sure that
my brother and i
had everything we needed but not
everything we wanted
my parents raised me to believe that in
america i could achieve
anything with hard work and
determination that the opportunities
available to me
were limited only by the size of my
ambition
that i should dream big and i did
those very dreams are what led me to new
york city i'd heard the adage if i could
make it there
i could make it anywhere and i intended
to do just that
never in a million years did i think
that i would be on this stage tonight
and i certainly never thought that i'd
end up with the last name trump
my seventh grade english teacher mrs b
used to tell us
believe none of what you hear half of
what you read
and only what you're there to witness
firsthand
the meaning of those words never fully
weighed on me until i met my husband
and the trump family any preconceived
notion i had of this family
disappeared immediately they were warm
and caring
they were hard workers and they were
down to earth
they reminded me of my own family they
made me feel like i was home
walking the halls of the trump
organization i saw the same family
environment
i also saw the countless women
executives who thrived there
year after year gender didn't matter
what mattered was the ability to get the
job done
i learned this directly when in 2016 my
father-in-law
asked me to help him win my cherished
home state
and my daughter's namesake north
carolina
though i had no political experience he
believed in me
he knew i was capable even if i didn't
so it didn't surprise me when president
donald trump appointed
so many women to senior level positions
in his administration
she wasn't surprised secretary of the
united nations secretary of the air
force
the first female cia director the first
black female director of the fish and
wildlife service
and countless ambassadors just to name a
few
under president trump's leadership
women's unemployment hit the lowest
level
since world war ii 4.3 million new jobs
have been created for women
in 2019 alone women took over 70 percent
of all new jobs female small business
ownership
remains at an all-time high and 600 000
women have been lifted
out of poverty all since president trump
took office
he didn't do these things to gain a vote
or check a box
he did them because they're the right
things to do
100 years ago today the 19th amendment
was ratified
granting the right to vote to every
american woman
and since that day incredible strides
have been made by women in america
from amelia earhart to rosa parks and
sally ride
women shaped our history and are part of
what has made our country the most
exceptional nation
in the world i often think back to my 24
year old self
driving alone in my car from north
carolina to new york city
and i think about what i tell myself now
as we head towards the most critical
election
in modern history this is not just a
choice between republican and democrat
or left and right this is an election
that will decide
if we keep america america
or if we head down an uncharted
frightening path
towards socialism aren't all of these
people coastal elites that they decry
america will never be destroyed from the
outside if we falter and lose our
freedoms
it will be because we destroyed
ourselves
while those words were spoken over 150
years ago
never have they been more relevant will
we choose the right path and maintain
the unique freedoms and boundless
opportunities
that make this country the greatest in
the history of the world
will we remain the beacon of hope for
those around the world fighting
oppression
communism and tyranny the choice is ours
i know the promise of america because
i've lived it
not just as a member of the trump family
but as a woman who knows what it's like
to work in blue collar jobs
to serve customers for tips and to
aspire to rise
when i look at my son luke and my
daughter carolina
i wonder what sort of country will i be
leaving for them
for our future generations in recent
months we've seen
weak spineless politicians seek control
of our great american cities
to violent mobs defund the police
is the rallying cry for the new radical
democrat party
joe biden will not do what it takes to
maintain order
to keep our children safe in our
neighborhoods and in their schools
to restore our american way of life
we cannot dare to dream our biggest
dreams for ourselves
or for our children while consumed by
worry about the safety of our families
president trump is the law and order
president from our borders to our
backyards
president trump will keep america safe
president trump will keep america
prosperous
president trump will keep america
america
if you're watching tonight and wrestling
with your vote on november 3rd
i implore you tune out the distorted
news and biased commentary
and hear it straight from someone who
knows
i wasn't born a trump i'm from the south
i was raised a carolina girl i went to
public schools and worked my way through
a state university
mrs b from my seventh grade english
class was right
what i learned about our president is
different than what you might have heard
i learned that he's a good man that he
loves his family
that he didn't need this job that no one
on earth works harder for the american
people
that he's willing to fight for his
beliefs and for the people
and the country that he loves he is a
person of conviction
he is a fighter and will never stop
fighting for america
he will uphold our values he will
preserve our families
and he will build upon the great
american edict that our union will never
be perfect
until opportunity is equal for all
including and especially for women
our 40th president ronald reagan said it
best
the dreams of people may differ but
everybody wants their dreams to come
true
and america above all places gives us
the freedom to do that
it's up to us to keep this country a
place where no dream is out of reach
for our children and generations beyond
to my father-in-law thank you for
believing in me
thank you for bravely leading this
country and thank you
for continuing to fight every day for
america
may god bless and protect the gulf
states in the path of the hurricane
may god bless our troops and may god
continue to bless this incredible
country how wholesome
wow what a wholesome speech some really
good super chats coming in
um james montalbano says it's really
very hard to believe this is reality
benefit says since we are on the subject
of
women in trump's administration let's
not forget what he did to marie
ivanovich
yes and then there was another good one
here oh
the price of drama says i really like
how positive and uplifting the past
three days have been david
no really my blood pressure has never
been at healthier levels
uh well said very very much uh well
well said the main event as it were
tonight
the sort of keynote uh address will be
from
mike vice president mike pence who's
going to be
accepting the renomination as vice
president
a thank you to procrastination
procrastination who has subscribed with
twitch prime
and his twitch subscriber 1406 while we
have a moment here
i want to get caught up on the number of
members we have a target of 56. we're
getting very close
okay number 39 is steve cote
number 40 is scott takala number 41
is the wpgirl.com
okay uh katherine hymes is number 42.
michael anderson is number 43 amber
fritz is 44
and alejandro barajas is number 45
so we are getting very very close to our
high
of 56 which was set on
monday and uh
let's see what else is coming in via
super chat darth vaden says are you
confident the don will win re-election
no i have no idea who's going to win i
think it really could go either
way first love smokers and barbecue says
has trump spoken to the family of jacob
blake
biden and harris have look it up i don't
believe that trump has
it does not appear that way jason nadal
says what do you think of the north pole
that claims trump has a 91 percent
chance of winning conservatives have
been touting it a solid proof of trump's
win
well hopefully it'll dis-incentivize
them
to um from voting and and they simply
won't vote
val mcclinchy says if you open the
phones will it be discord
the phones are not getting open tonight
val uh it's been
it's been some very very long days so i
am going right to bed when this is over
so
uh we we i have not even raised the
issue
of phones this evening unfortunately
unfortunately or fortunately depending
on your sp
your perspective on that a continued
demands for me to start and only fans
as i've said before i am not doing only
fans but i am on
cameo that is true i am on cameo but i'm
not going to be doing only fans
jrms productions says this is just
hurting my brain as a canadian this is
just so hard to watch
and i see them moving more right like
our conservatives here
are your democrats
um pop stackles says i know you've
touched on the subject but you've never
speculated about what you think the
answer is
or will be to dealing with the 60
million people that think this is
truthful
is the union breaking i don't know what
what this
viewer is alluding to as i've said
before win or lose
60 something million people are going to
vote for trump in november
and they're still going to live in this
country even if trump loses
how do we deal with that is the question
and i don't have an answer i don't have
an answer and i'm sort of
tabling the conversation let's get to
november 3rd first and then figure out
figure out the rest serge sambarak
says do you think trump will refuse to
leave the white house if he loses
i don't think so i think he will claim
it's rigged and i think he is going to
do what he can to to
justify that he won but ultimately
uh he will go because on if he loses on
january 20th he will no longer be
president
of the united states yabbitz says that
this convention has been just like an
amway convention
not altogether incorrect a lot of
components of that
blind loyalty uh delusional talking
points
suspension of any kind of critical
thinking or disbelief
uh scams so yeah very much so
um deretend says
david come to europe for a while we need
pacman
i would love to go to europe just not
allowed
dev elote says why haven't americans
been protesting the blatant voting
sabotage is that not a core right
there should be protesting of what's
going on with voting you're you're
completely correct from a moral
standpoint
awesome gaming says how do you think
trump well
will respond to the category 4 5
hurricane
i i have no idea i have no idea
peter orbach says i made latkes and
drank beer tonight i'm still sane
that's fantastic i haven't had a good
latke for a little while but
this is not a sponsor i just love it
over the weekend
i did go to michael's deli in brookline
i visited uh stephen and i bought a
whole bunch of knishes
a whole bunch of knishes people asking
how stephen kenneth destiny bonnell ii
got into sweden
i believe sweden is one of the places
that has
not banned americans now the truth is i
have friends who are in europe and the
way they did it is
they went to the uk for 14 days and
quarantined
which you're allowed to do as an
american then they went to other
countries
and entered as people coming from europe
because that's what they did
so like i get it i get it it could be
done
it could be done but will i do it that's
a different question
very different question a thank you to
zach
salmi who is new member number 46 today
at joinpacman.com we are now just 10
members
from reaching our monday record of 56 in
one stream
not an all-time record but it was the
highest from any stream
evening um
okay it looked like people were reacting
very strongly to what i said about the
european stuff but it
seems people have calmed down we are
down to roughly
the last 40 or 45 minutes of night three
the good news is after
this we will be 75 of the way through
and we will have just tomorrow left to
go
the bad news is we have to still listen
to mike pence give a speech
and i'm expecting that it'll probably be
in about
uh 20 minutes or so
numbered says is destiny justified the
kenosha shooter
destiny justified the kenosha shooter
what's your response
i didn't see that that sounds crazy
but i didn't see it so it'd be hard to
respond michael henckley says
trump will nuke the hurricane derek
miller says
my boss keeps telling people if trump
loses then she knows for a fact
the election was rigged her only
reasoning she gives
is because she knows democrats who are
voting for trump
yikes yikes that's scary stuff
um okay do people i think this this one
we should listen to this is grinnell
right yeah
one outsider stood alone and said in
public
what most americans thought in private
it was 14 years after the start of the
war in afghanistan
and 12 years after the invasion of iraq
where
thousands of american troops had died
and trillions in taxpayer dollars had
been spent
and yet no candidate could bring
themselves to admit that something had
gone
badly wrong with american foreign policy
that the american voter the american
soldier
and the american taxpayer had all been
let down
except for one donald trump
he called america's endless wars what
they were
a disaster the media was shocked
because donald trump was running as a
republican
and yet he said out loud what we all
knew
that american foreign policy was failing
to make
americans safer
after the end of the cold war just need
new batteries republicans in washington
bought into the illusion that the whole
world would start to resemble
america and so they started to pursue
unlimited globalization they welcomed
china into the world trade organization
they engaged in nation building in
afghanistan
and tried to export democracy to iraq
they signed a nuclear deal with iran
nuclear global
climate agreement in paris
but they didn't ground any of it in the
interests of the average
american so for decades while washington
politicians built a global system
american wages stagnated our great
cities and industries were hollowed out
entire communities were devastated and
our manufacturing plants were shipped
off to china
that's what happened when washington
stopped being the capital of the united
states
and started being the capital of the
world
as u.s ambassador to germany i had a
front row seat to donald trump's america
first foreign policy
i wish every american could see how
president trump negotiates on their
behalf
i've watched president trump charm the
chancellor of germany
that's interesting trump negotiates for
sport and to feel like he's winning
things he's not negotiating for
americans
does president trump say to foreign
leaders i don't blame you for wanting
america to pay for your security i
actually respect you for out negotiating
the presidents before me
but it stops with me i won't let the
american taxpayer be taken advantage of
donald trump's administration has always
made clear
that our priority is the american
people's security
that's the job of all leaders to put
their people first
and we've seen how this strategy has
succeeded
in four short years donald trump has led
even
some washington democrats to agree on
the chinese threat
on trade deals that benefit america
first
on alliances that share responsibility
in four years donald trump didn't start
any new wars
he brought troops home he rebuilt the
military
and signed peace deals that make
americans safer
the washington elites want you to think
this kind of foreign policy is immoral
and so they call it nationalist
that tells you all you need to know the
d.c
crowd thinks when they call donald trump
a nationalist they're insulting
him as if the american president
isn't supposed to base foreign policy on
america's
national interests a return to the biden
way of thinking means america gives the
radical terrorist regime in tehran
a plain load of cash in the middle of
the night
well you see president trump also sent
an aircraft in the middle of the night
to deal with iran
but that plane was on a different
mission an
air strike to take out the head of
iran's terror machine who plotted the
deaths of americans
but we also must be clear this is vile
that when those who seek freedom
take tremendous personal risk in places
like hong kong tehran
or minsk there is no doubt who president
trump's administration supports
we will always stand with the people who
fight for
their god-given freedoms
don't be fooled the washington
establishment
is trying to sell you on their candidate
joe biden was first elected to the
senate in 1972 that was a weird cut i
don't know if anybody noticed that
i wonder what the deal with that was
well it's actually the typical
washington story
just this year 22 democrats ran for
president
they rejected all of the outsiders and
nominated the ultimate
washington insider someone they had to
pull out of retirement
every time joe biden offers a new idea
you should ask yourself
why didn't he try that over the last 48
years
today the democrats blame a global
yesterday it was 47 now it's 48 years
and they still blame russia for hillary
clinton's loss in 19
in 2016. as acting director of national
intelligence
i saw the democrats entire case for
russian collusion
and what i saw made me sick to my
stomach
the obama biden administration secretly
launched a surveillance operation on the
trump campaign
and silenced the many brave intelligence
officials
who spoke up against it they presented
bogus information as facts
they lied to judges then they classified
anything that undermined their case and
after donald trump
won the election when they should have
continued the american tradition
of helping the president-elect
transition into the white house
they tried instead to undercut him even
more
understand none of this is true
president joe biden
asked intelligence officials to uncover
the hidden information on president
trump's incoming national security
adviser
three weeks before the inauguration
that's the democrats between
surveillance
classifications leaks and puppet
candidates
they never want the american people to
know who's actually calling the shots
but with donald trump you always know
exactly who is in charge
because the answer is you
you're in charge not lobbyists not
special interests
not war mongers or china sympathizers or
globalization fanatics
with donald trump and mike pence in the
white house the boss is the american
people
president trump rightly calls his
foreign policy
america first america first does not
advance the interests of one group of
americans at the expense of another
it has no bias about red or blue
educated or not educated urban
or rural america first is simply the
belief
that politicians should focus on the
equality
and dignity of every american
and that this duty is fulfilled by
promoting the safety and wealth
of the american people above all else
that's america first that's the trump
doctrine
and that my friends is four more years
whoa uh i'm gonna be in recovery mode
for a while
from taking in all of those very low
level ideas so i'm
gonna need to excuse myself momentarily
uh now we begin building towards the
keynote of night three which is going to
be vice president
mike pence um that could be anywhere
from
you know five to maybe 15 minutes from
now
unclear how long mike pence will speak
hopefully not
inordinately long because it is going to
be very difficult to get through
but the good news is that a lot of fine
people
very fine people on my side are signing
up on my website new member number 47
today
is catherine keener new member number 48
is michael doerr
joey saint claire is new member number
49.
pura shodham gosai is new member number
50
and paul yanchek is number 51
putting us very strongly within striking
distance of 56 which was monday's record
at joinpakman.com they're going back to
some propaganda videos let me see what
people are saying
uh over here via super chat brad smith
says they say they want to be inclusive
and open to all americans while at the
same time insulting democrats which is a
good portion of this country
of course let's see here
um some ting wong
is quoting donald trump i like this this
is a quote from trump
i moved on her i just start kissing them
i don't even wait and when you're a star
they let you do it you can do anything
grab them by thee you know what
the price of dreams says david i'm
drowning in the cognitive dissonance and
hypocrisy that comes in claiming
the opposing side presented bogus
information as facts please help
uh can't help you there
i wish i could help uh oddax
asks did richard grinnell forget about
impeachment
johann walston says i can't understand
how people can buy these last four years
if you weren't emotional bias which
is end disorder d can you explain how
this could go so wrong johann
i love the support i'm having a little
trouble parsing the exact question
you're asking
but i do really really appreciate the
support
uh samantha slayin some sorry samantha b
slayin says voting for biden on november
3rd
is the only way this insanity will stop
biden harris 2020 as we prepare
for some weaponized disinformation
propaganda
from vice president mike pence
expecting him any moment now uh as far
as we've been told
guests that will be in the crowd i guess
there will be a crowd
have not been tested for coronavirus
tonight
and uh you know you tell me how much of
a risk you think that is
playable tengu says trump didn't start
any new wars then proceeds to brag about
trump inching us to the brink of war
with iran i'm baffled
yeah trump didn't start any new wars but
let me brag about trump bombing iran
very weird very very weird
a thanks to lil stu live for subscribing
with twitch prime
also jeff and jax has subscribed with
prime
zizak and egalitarian beggar
as well as gina doodle damien zander
the napkins have all subscribed with
prime
by popular demand the number of twitch
subscribers
on screen throughout the evening 1413
currently
one four one three that's the number
that is a high water mark we've never
had at any point
uh from the standpoint of twitch we have
never had more than
14 13 active subscriptions
um we've been some people seem to want
the audio do people want the propaganda
video we've just been skipping the
propaganda videos
that uh uh come up in advance of
speeches but i'm glad to play it if
people want it
seems pretty split a lot of no's
oh but some people are saying it is the
pence one so that we should be watching
it all right
let's check it out i'm gonna get a
refill of my water momentarily and then
we'll see the speech
guide our country and every one of us
to greater heights in this land of the
free
and home of the brave
vice president mike pence
oh my god is there a pandemic right now
please welcome the vice president of the
united states
mike pence accompanied by the secondly
mrs karen pence
is she his chaperone or is he
chaperoning her i don't even get it
it's like there's no pandemic going on
this gigantic crowd with no masks
reportedly wasn't even covered tested
[Music]
all right i'll be back
[Music]
oh
good evening america it's an honor to
speak to you tonight
from the hallowed the hallowed grounds
of fort mchenry
the site of the very battle that
inspired the words of our national
anthem
those words have inspired this land of
heroes in every generation since
it was on this site 206 years ago
when our young republic heroically
withstood a ferocious naval bombardment
from the most powerful empire on earth
they came to crush our revolution to
divide our nation
and to end the american experiment
the heroes who held this fort took their
stand for life
liberty freedom
and the american flag and those ideals
have defined our nation
but they were hardly ever mentioned at
last week's democratic national
convention
instead democrats spent four days
attacking
america joe biden said that
we were living through a season of
darkness
but as president trump said where joe
biden sees american darkness
we see american greatness
in these challenging times our country
needs a president who believes in
america
who believes in the boundless capacity
of the american people
to meet any challenge defeat any foe
and defend the freedoms we hold dear
america
needs four more years of president
donald trump in the white house
before i go further allow me to say a
word to the families and communities in
the path of hurricane laura
our prayers are with you tonight and our
administration is working closely with
authorities in the states that will be
impacted
fema has mobilized resources and
supplies for those in harm's way
this is a serious storm and we urge all
those in the affected areas to heed
state and local authorities
stay safe and know that we'll be with
you every step of the way
to support rescue respond
and recover in the days and weeks ahead
that's what americans do
four years ago i answered the call to
join this ticket
because i knew that donald trump had the
leadership
and the vision to make america great
again
and for the last four years i've watched
this president endure unrelenting
attacks but get
up every day and fight to keep the
promises that he made to the american
people
so with gratitude for the confidence
president donald trump has placed in me
the support of our republican party and
the grace of god
i humbly accept your nomination to run
and serve
as vice president of the united states
i can tell i just missed propaganda
somebody please tell me what i just
missed
[Applause]
serving the american people in this
office has been a journey i never
expected
it's a journey that would not have been
possible
without the support of my family
beginning with my wonderful wife karen
has anybody spread the virus yet an
incredible mother to our three children
and she is one outstanding second lady
of the united states i'm so proud of you
and we couldn't be more proud of our
three children
marine corps captain michael j pence and
his wife sarah our daughter
charlotte pence bond an author
and the wife to lieutenant henry bond
who is currently deployed and serving
our nation
in the united states navy
and our youngest a recent law school
grad
our daughter audrey and her fiance who
like so many other americans had to
delay their wedding this summer but we
can't wait for dan to be a part of our
family
in addition to my wife and kids
the person who shaped my life the most
is also with us tonight
my mom nancy
she is the daughter of an irish
immigrant
87 years young and mom follows politics
very closely and the truth be told
sometimes i think i'm actually her
second favorite
candidate on the trump pence ticket
oh god what an invitation thank you mom
i love you
[Applause]
over the past four years
i've had the privilege to work closely
with our president
i've seen him when the cameras are off
americans see president trump in lots of
different ways
fair but there's no doubt how president
trump sees america
he sees america for what it is
a nation that has done more good in this
world than any other
a nation that deserves far more
gratitude than grievance
and if you want a president who falls
silent when our heritage is demeaned or
insulted
he's not your man
okay
now we came by very different routes to
this partnership
and some people think we're a little bit
different
but you know i've learned a few things
watching him
watching him deal with all that we've
been through over the past four years
he does things in his own way on his own
terms
not much gets past him and when he has
an opinion
he's liable to share it
he certainly kept things interesting
but more importantly president donald
trump has kept
his word to the american people
in a city known for talkers president
trump is a doer
and few presidents have brought more
independence
energy or determination to that office
four years ago we inherited a military
hollowed out
by devastating budget cuts that's a hell
of an economy struggling to break out
of the slowest recovery since the great
depression that's a lie
isis controlled a land mass twice the
size of pennsylvania
that's true and we witnessed a steady
assault
on our most cherished values freedom of
religion
and the right to life that's when
president donald trump stepped in
and from day one he kept his word
we rebuilt our military
this president signed the largest
increase in our national defense since
the days of ronald reagan
and created the first new branch of our
armed forces
in 70 years the united states space
force
come on guys
and with that renewed energy we also
returned american astronauts to space
on an american rocket for the first time
in nearly 10 years
nothing to do with this administration
that was years of scandal
that robbed our veterans of the care
that you earned
in the uniform of the united states
president trump kept his word again
we reformed the va and veterans choice
is now
available for every veteran in america
that's an obama policy from 2014.
obama our armed forces and our veterans
fill this land of heroes
and many join us tonight in this
historic fort
tonight we have among us four recipients
of the medal of honor
six recipients of the purple heart
it's sort of like a low rent state of
the union her mother
of a gallon navy sea
and wounded warriors from soldier strong
a group that serves our injured veterans
every day
we are honored by your presence and we
thank you for your service
[Music]
with heroes just like these we defend
this nation every day
and under this commander-in-chief we've
taken the fight to radical islamic
terrorists on our terms
on their soil last year american armed
forces took the last inch of isis
territory
crushed their caliphate and took down
their leader without one
american casualty
and i was there when president trump
gave the order to take out the world's
most dangerous terrorists
iran's top general will never harm
another
american because qasim salamani
is gone
my fellow americans you deserve to know
joe biden criticized president trump
following those decisions
decisions to rid the world of two
terrorist leaders you deserve to know
that
but it's not surprising because history
records that joe biden even opposed the
operation
that took down osama bin laden
it's no wonder that the secretary
of defense under the obama biden
administration once said
that joe biden has been and i quote
wrong on nearly every major foreign
policy and national security issue
over the past four decades
so we've stood up to our enemies and
we've stood with our allies
like when president trump kept his word
and moved
the american embassy to jerusalem the
capital
of the state of israel that plays really
well at this convention
the first arab country to recognize
israel
in 26 years
closer to home we appointed more than
200 conservative judges to our federal
courts
we supported the right to life and all
the god-given liberties enshrined in our
constitution including the second
amendment right to keep and bear arms
and when it came to the economy
president trump kept his word and then
some
we passed the largest tax cut and reform
in american history
we rolled back more federal red tape
than any administration
ever had we unleashed american energy
meaningless places fought for free and
fair trade
and in our first three years businesses
large and small created more than 7
million good paying jobs including 500
000 manufacturing jobs all across
america
our country became a net exporter of
energy for the first time
in 70 years unemployment rates for
african americans
and hispanic americans hit the lowest
level ever recorded
and on this 100th anniversary of the
woman's right to vote
i'm proud to report that under president
donald trump we achieved the lowest
unemployment rate
for women in 65 years
so that's sort of a math game when the
unemployment rate is low it's it's low
for most groups you could say
i mean you know is it low for american
samoans or whatever it's not really
substantive trade again
and then the coronavirus struck from
china
before the first case of the coronavirus
spread within the united states
the president took unprecedented action
and suspended
all travel from china the second largest
economy in the world brace yourselves
now that action saved untold american
lives
and i can tell you first hand it bought
us
invaluable time to launch the greatest
national mobilization since world war
ii president trump marshaled the full
resources of our federal government from
the outset
marshall he directed us to forge a
seamless partnership
with governors across america in both
political parties
we partnered with private industry to
reinvent testing
and produce supplies that that were
distributed to hospitals around the land
today we're conducting more than eight
hundred thousand
tests a day and we have coordinated the
delivery of
billions of pieces of personal
protective
equipment for our amazing doctors nurses
and health care workers
we saw to the manufacturer of a hundred
thousand ventilators in a hundred days
and no one who required a ventilator was
ever
denied a ventilator in the united states
that's unclear it's unclear that that's
true
we built hospitals surged military
medical personnel
and enacted an economic rescue package
that saved 50 million american jobs as
we speak
we're developing a growing number of
treatments
known as therapeutics including
convalescent plasma that are
none of that has been developed in the
united states even never mind
by anybody having to do with the trump
administration
that no miracle is coming
well what joe doesn't seem to understand
is that america is a nation of miracles
and i'm proud to report that we're on
track to have the world's first
safe effective coronavirus vaccine by
the end of this year
after all the sacrifice in this year
like no other
all the hardship we're finding our way
forward again
but tonight our hearts are with all the
families who've lost loved ones
and have family members still struggling
with serious illness
in this country we mourn with those who
mourn we grieve with those who grieve
and this night i know that millions of
americans will pause
and pray for god's comfort for each of
you
this is delusionally gross you know our
country doesn't get through
such a time unless its people find
strength within
the response of doctors nurses first
responders
farmers factory workers truckers and
everyday americans
who put the health and safety of their
neighbors first
has been nothing short of heroic
veronica says put on her scrubs
every day day in and day out went to
work in one of new york city's busiest
hospitals
she stayed on the job put in the long
hours until it was done
and then got back in her neighborhood
and help neighbors and friends
struggling
her brother william is a new york city
firefighter
and they're both emblematic of heroes
all across this country
they're with us tonight and i say to
them
and to all of you you have earned the
admiration of the american
people and we will always be grateful
for your service
and care
this is a perfect example of like okay
but so
because they did interesting and good
things in new york why would we vote for
trump and pence
and if you react i mean it's playing on
people's emotion but it
it actually does not have anything to do
with trump and pence's reelection
[Applause]
thanks to the courage and compassion of
the american people
we're slowing the spread we're
protecting the vulnerable
and we're saving lives and we're opening
up america again
because of the strong foundation that
president trump poured in our first
three years
we've already gained back 9.3 million
jobs in the last three months alone
is that of the 47 million lost or what's
the math on that
cup america again we're opening up
america's schools
and i'm proud to report that my wife
karen
that school teacher i've been married to
will be returning to her classroom
next week and so to all of our heroic
teachers and faculty and staff
thank you for being there for our kids
we're going to stay with you
every step of the way
in the days ahead as we open up america
again
i promise you we'll continue to put the
health of america first
and as we work to bring this economy
back
we all have a role to play and we all
have a choice to make
on november 3rd you need to ask yourself
who do you trust to rebuild this economy
fair
a career politician who presided over
the slowest economic recovery
since the great depression or a proven
leader
who created the greatest economy in the
world
the choice is clear yeah to bring
america
all the way back we need four more years
of president donald trump
this guy right here in the standard
republican outfit of the blue blazer and
the khakis led the standing out
my fellow americans were passing through
a time of testing
but in the midst of this global pandemic
just as our nation had begun to recover
we've seen violence and chaos in the
streets of our major cities
president trump and i will always
support the right of americans to
peaceful protest
but rioting and looting is not peaceful
protest
tearing down statues is not free speech
and those who do so will be prosecuted
to the fullest extent of the law
yeah those are local decisions based on
existing law i mean
those are their crimes sure last week
joe biden didn't say
one word about the violence and chaos
engulfing cities across this country
so let me be clear the violence must
stop
whether in minneapolis portland or
kenosha
too many heroes have died defending our
freedom
to see americans strike each other down
we will have
law and order on the streets of this
country for every american
of every race and creed and color
don't know about you but that's bingo
for me
president trump and i know that the men
and women that put on the uniform of law
enforcement
are the best of us every day
when they walk out that door they
consider
our lives more important than their own
people like dave patrick underwood uh-oh
an officer in the department of homeland
security's federal protective service
who was shot and killed during the riots
in oakland california
dave's heroism is emblematic
of the heroes that serve in blue every
day
and we're privileged tonight to be
joined by his sister angela
angela we say to you we we grieve with
your family
and america will never forget or fail
to honor officer dave patrick
underwood
the american people know we don't have
to choose between supporting law
enforcement
and standing with our african-american
neighbors
to improve the quality of their lives
education jobs and safety
and from the first days of this
administration we've
done both and we will keep supporting
law enforcement and keep supporting our
african
american and minority communities across
this
land for four more years
the hell is going on here guys
joe biden says that america is
systemically racist
and that law enforcement in america
has and i quote an implicit bias
against minorities when asked whether
he'd support cutting funding in law
enforcement
joe biden replied yes absolutely
joe biden would double down on the very
policies that are leading
to violence in america's cities
the hard truth is
you won't be safe in joe biden's america
and under president trump
we will always stand with those who
stand up it's weird because
all they talk about is how unsafe
everything is now but
trump's president now it seems people
are unsafe now right
my fellow americans were passing through
a time of testing
but soon we will come to a time for
choosing
joe biden has referred to himself as a
transition candidate
and many were asking transition to what
out of insanity
but last week democrats didn't talk very
much about their agenda
and if i were them i wouldn't either
i mean bernie sanders did tell his
followers that joe biden would be the
most liberal president in modern times
in fact
he said and i quote that
many of the ideas he fought for
that just a few years ago were
considered radical
are now mainstream they're now
mainstream in the democratic party
in america at the root of their agenda
is the belief that america is driven by
envy
not aspiration now that millions of
americans harbor ill will toward
our neighbors instead of loving our
neighbors as ourselves
the radical left believes that the
federal government must be involved in
every aspect of our lives to correct
those american wrongs no
they believe the federal government
needs to dictate how americans live how
we should work
how we should raise our children and in
the process deprive our people of
freedom
prosperity and security i don't hear
anyone saying that their agenda is based
on government control
our agenda is based on freedom
trump's literally sending in troops
overriding mayors and governors
how is that not an agenda of government
control trillion dollars
where this president achieved energy
independence for the united states
joe biden would abolish fossil fuels
end fracking that sounds great impose a
regime of climate change regulations
that would drastically
increase the cost of living for working
families
where we fought for free and fair trade
and this president stood up to china and
ended the era of economic surrender
joe biden has been a cheerleader for
communist china
he wants to repeal all the tariffs that
are leveling the playing field
for american workers tariffs are insane
and he actually criticized
president trump for suspending all
travel to china
at the outset of this pandemic joe biden
is for open borders
no sanctuary cities free lawyers in
health care for illegal immigrants
and president trump he secured our
border
and built nearly 300 miles of that
border wall
joe biden wants to end school choice
president trump believes that every
parent should have the right to choose
where their children go to school
regardless of their income or area code
president trump president trump
has stood without apology for the
sanctity of human life
every day of this administration
joe biden he supports taxpayer funding
of abortion
right up to the moment of birth
when you consider their agenda it's
clear
joe biden would be nothing more than a
trojan horse
for the radical left unfortunately this
election has never been
clearer and the stakes have never been
higher
last week joe biden said democracy's on
the ballot
and the truth is our economic recovery
is on the ballot
true law and order are on the ballot in
a sense yes
but so are things far more fundamental
and foundational to our country
in this election it's not so much
whether
america will be more conservative or
more liberal
more republican or more democratic it's
whether it will be sane
the choice in this election is whether
america remains america
it's whether we will leave to our
children and our grandchildren
a country grounded in our highest ideals
of freedom free markets and the
unalienable right to life and liberty
or whether we will leave them a country
that's fundamentally transformed into
something else
we stand at a crossroads america this is
terrible
president trump has set our nation on a
path of freedom and opportunity
joe biden would set america on a path of
socialism and decline
nothing socialist about but we're not
gonna let it happen
he's center left
president donald trump believes in
america and in the goodness of the
american people
the boundless potential of every
american to live out their dreams and
freedom
and every day president trump has been
fighting to protect the promise of
america
every day our president has been
fighting to expand the reach of the
american dream
every day president donald trump has
been fighting for you
and now it's our turn to fight for him
time to wrap
on this night in the company of heroes
i'm deeply grateful
deeply grateful for the privilege of
serving as vice president of this great
nation
and to have the opportunity to serve
again what would make the speech worse
guys i pray to be worthy of him
and i will give that duty all that's in
me 20 more minutes yeah
in the year 2020 the american people
have had more than our share of
challenges
but thankfully we have a president with
the toughness
energy and resolve to see us through
now those traits actually run in our
national character
as the invading force learned on
approach to this fort
in september of 1814
against fierce and sustained bombardment
our young country was defended by heroes
not so different from those who are with
us tonight
the enemy was counting on them to quit
but they never did
fort mchenry held
and when morning came
our flag was still here
profound
my fellow americans we're going through
a time of testing
but if you look through the fog of these
challenging times
you will see
our flag is still there today
that star-spangled banner still waves
over the land of the free and the home
of the brave
from these hallowed grounds american
patriots and generations gone by did
their part to defend freedom
no it's our turn yeah this guy can't
possibly keep it together in a debate
against kamala right i mean she's going
to make mincemeat out of him
let's fix our eyes on oh glory
and all she represents
let's fix our eyes on this land of
heroes
and let their courage inspire i think
he's going all night
and let's fix our eyes on the author and
perfecter
of our faith and our freedom
and never forget that where the spirit
of the lord is
there is freedom that means
freedom always wins
my fellow americans thank you for the
honor of addressing you tonight
and the opportunity to run and serve
again as your vice president
right i leave here today inspired
and i leave here today more convinced
than ever
that we will do in our time
as americans have done throughout our
long and storied past
we will defend our freedom and our way
of life
we will reelect our president and
principled republican leaders across the
land
and with president donald trump in the
white house for four more years
and with god's help ah we will make
america
great again wait so you didn't do it yet
oh okay
thank you god bless you and god bless
the united states
this is what you call red meat
dog whistle nationalist nonsense
and um probably from the standpoint of
people
already voting trump a speech they will
like
i mean let's be honest this is the type
of stuff that plays well with these
folks
um dear god
oh my god is trump coming out now oh my
god he is
[Music]
watch the cringe here
[Music]
trump can't stay away he has to be there
every he has to be the focus every night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
dear god oh my god he's so orange
is trump amber what's the name of this
shade
what's the name of that huge
bronze ochre it's ochre yeah i like that
[Applause]
cinnamon it's not really
here to cinnamon our national effort
please welcome country music superstar
trace atkins oh my god
trace atkins is horrible
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm out guys not gonna do it um that
almost seems like a character voice so
uh that's gonna do it for me we will see
everybody tomorrow congratulations
you've i just can't i mean listen to
that
[Music]
i just can't do it okay um we're 75 of
the way through
i'll see everybody tomorrow night
you